zéro ce qui est le plus frappant quand
on rencontre benoît clair c'est son rire
spontané qui éclatent à tout bout de
champ l'exposition rigole même lorsque
nous explique qu'il n'a plus un rond que
toutes ses économies se sont envolés et
ses économies bornéo où il a investi
dans la rénovation d'un édifice conte
destiné à la démolition pour en faire
une épicerie
[Musique]
comme s'ils venaient à entre 2 to
légumes conserves vêtements d'hiver
crème glacée pour les enfants le film à
mon ami pour de vrai en soi rien de bien
extraordinaire portant dans ce quartier
de la nouvelle orléans
l'ouverture de ce commerce est un petit
miracle
[Musique]
tuberculosis il ya quinze ans déjà deux
puisqu'ils coeur de céline dion devant
l'ampleur de la catastrophe causée par
l'ouragan katrina le 29 août 2005 la
digue qui retient les eaux du
mississippi a cédé ici même
la tempête se transforme alors en
tragédie quand les résidants du lower
ninth se retrouve prisonnier leur toit
de leur voiture
des centaines de personnes perdent la
vie noyer le quartier se transforme en
véritable cauchemar
le coaching de ce débat que l'austérité
encore temps plus tard le quartier le
plus touché par catherine avis toujours
un cauchemar
le lower ninth est encore aujourd'hui
une ruine des ollies désertique les
maisons abandonnées voisine les terrains
vagues et aucun commerce n'a jamais
rouvert même si près de 7000 personnes
vivent
[Musique]
depuis 2009 il se consacre désormais à
son quartier il travaille sept jours par
semaine en compagnie de sa mère libye
même si les reebok ou bernal quatre
mêmes plats aussi souvent et en os by
night lights sommes sentis pour vous
cela comme les décennies 60 et
[Musique]
ce n'est pas le tiers-monde non
n'empêche 25 millions d'américains
vivent dans ce qu'on appelle des déserts
alimentaires des zones dépourvues de
source d'aliments sains à un coût
acceptable
[Musique]
les magasins à un dollar eux ce sont par
ailleurs multipliés aux etats unis au
cours des dernières années
si bien qu'on en compte maintenant plus
de 30 milles soit davantage que deux
restaurants mecs dans notre doux
starbucks rim les américains pauvres y
font leur épicerie de surgelés gras et
sucrés un cercle vicieux donc dans une
amérique où près de 40% des américains
sont obèses
mais même les magasins à un dollar n'ont
pas daigné traverser le pont qui sépare
le lower ninth du reste de la nouvelle
orléans
[Musique]
mais en 2015
bernard s'est résolu à lancer un appel
aux stars dennis wood pour financer
l'achat de machines à laver des milliers
de personnes du quartier n'en possèdent
pas et devait entreprendre un périple en
vélo ou en autobus pour trouver une
buanderie son plus récent ajout à
l'épicerie un salon de barbier et dans
ce désert le veer de bonheur constitue
en soi un noise
[Musique]
non